c'est historique car c'est une première
pour un ancien président de la
République la condamnation pour
corruption est trafic d'influence à
l'encontre de Nicolas Sarkozy dans
l'affaire des écoutes a été confirmée en
appel soit une peine de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement dont un an ferme à
purger sous bracelet électronique
présent à l'audience Nicolas Sarkozy 68
ans n'a fait aucun commentaire son
avocate immédiatement annoncé quel est
les former pour voir en cassation cette
décision
elle
est câble contestable endroit en fait et
nous ne lâcherons pas
ce combat là qui est un combat juste
face à une décision particulièrement
unique et injuste le pourvoi est
suspensif Nicolas Sarkozy est le premier
ancien président condamné à de la prison
ferme trois ans de prison dont un
enferme qu'il aurait dû purger avec un
porte de bracelet électronique c'est
pour ça que vous allez voir sur les
réseaux tourner ce vieux tweet de
l'ex-président c'était en 2015 il
réclamait la fin des aménagements de
peine pour les délinquants condamnés à
des peines de plus de six mois on peut
pas avoir un vrai en fait une quinzaine
en fait vous êtes un intellectuel vous
êtes un intellectuel et vous êtes
incapable d'écouter et de répondre
pardonnez-moi de vous dire comme ça Eric
et bah vous répondrez après c'est tout
vrai d'abord ça dure pas duré 5 minutes
ça durait deux minutes et vous le coupez
en permanence donc c'est très
désagréable Yann Barthès qui est donc
incapable de trouver des vannes plus
récentes que celles il y a deux ans dans
cette émission en réalité on apprend
rien une personne qui est de mauvaise
foi qui est pas drôle on arrête en fait
de vous regarder parce que ce que vous
faites c'est
à peu près nul puisque vous écoutez bien
c'est pas mais non Erico
tout à fait vrai
en plus de tout le monde et en plus il
est vexé il est
et vous allez vous allez vous y serez
très bien
quand on a envie de s'informer on
regarde pas la télé et pourtant il a
accepté notre invitation merci de bien
vouloir éteindre la télé voici le député
Antoine Léman
ce niveau de discussion je suis surpris
d'avoir mais est-ce que je peux terminer
le trivialement je m'en je m'en vais
vous l'avez dit maintenant mais vous
allez vous n'écoutez rien et si je vais
vous répondre que ça n'existe
allez-y un enfant quoi
Yann Barthès qui essaie de faire le
jeune le coup le mec rigolo avec des
vannes et tout machins et bien il passe
juste pour un vieux et un nul et
quelqu'un de l'ancien monde qui ne
comprend pas le nouveau monde de
l'information dans lequel on est entré
ok cette fonctionnalité de WhatsApp donc
application de messagerie du groupe
métaP propose à ses utilisateurs de
garder leur petit jardin secret
numérique voilà le principe si vous avez
une conversation que vous jugez sensible
et bien vous pouvez désormais la cacher
dans un dossier à part et pour ouvrir ce
dossier vous devez taper un code secret
ou alors vous pouvez utiliser la
reconnaissance faciale ou alors votre
empreinte digitale autant vous dire que
Fort Knox n'a qu'à bien se tenir on a
une Gesta
cette gestard c'est la personne qui gère
les éléments de langage d'Olivier du
soft on accueille ce pipeau le pipeau
voilà vous êtes donc bien plus drôle que
moi et c'est une grande selon WhatsApp
qui dit c'est idéal si quelqu'un d'autre
que vous évidemment utilise votre
téléphone au moment précis où vous
recevez un message spécial et on imagine
que ce message 10 spécial à de grandes
chances d'être truffés d'emoji de cœur
d'aubergines de tout ce que vous voulez
agit il nous met de la litière dans un
bain ça ressemble
à quelque chose qui pendouille un truc
qui pendouille non non on voit vraiment
pas
[Musique]
le temps de dresser là
c'est le moment de la petite bague qui
va bien t'as pas vu de faire défiler
tu avais tout près
j'étais dépassé par le temps et puis
chef étivait si il rentre à fond dans le
jeu assez énorme et pourquoi tu dis rien
moi je pensais que tu avais fini non
c'est pas que je faisais rien c'est
juste j'ai pas vu le temps de passer je
me suis concentré sur le liquide bon on
le surnomme docteur Dipsy pour docteur
des eaux profondes car il a battu le
record de l'homme ayant vécu le plus
longtemps sous l'eau 73 jours un
quotidien hors du commun depuis début
mars dans un lodge sous-marin pour
Joseph diuri mais cette américain de 55
ans ancien plongeur de l'US Navy s'est
lancé un défi encore plus fou atteindre
les 100 jours l'expérience a été
baptisée Neptune et sert à prouver les
bienfaits d'une immersion sous l'eau
pour le corps humain
c'est incroyable il fait un bruit de
goutte d'eau
à quoi ça sert strictement rien c'est
pour ça qu'on adore ce talent
donc dans le verre
puis c'est tout quoi c'est tout
robinet tu sais
bien c'est arrivé très rarement chef
dans l'histoire du concours
c'est génial mais effectivement parfois
vous savez que le temps est à la seconde
près je suis vraiment désolé pour vous
Hugo 16% c'est notre chiffre du jour et
c'est la part de Français qui déclare ne
pas manger à leur fin selon la dernière
étude du Crédoc le centre de recherche
pour l'étude et l'observation des
conditions de vie un chiffre qui a
bondit en seulement quelques mois la
part des Français se privant de
nourriture est ainsi passé de 12 à 16%
donc en six mois principalement
l'inflation et la flambée des prix de
l'alimentaire l'idée l'idée c'était de
vous surprendre à écrire en fait rigoler
surprendre
oser oser faire ça donc voilà laisse
regarder peut-être que il faut avoir
peut-être une surprise je sais pas
[Musique]
extraordinaire s'est mis à la cuisine
exactement et en terme d'audience ça
pourrait cartonner sur notre plateau
alors comme ça c'est très joli pour
goûter l'orange mais moi ce que je
préfère c'est la prendre à demain
l'ouvrir plonger le nez dedans la
dévorer avoir les huiles qui s'auto
visage et savourait toutes ses chair
voilà
et après tu croques vas-y croc
quelle sensation on a lorsqu'on lèche
une langue comme ça alors c'est
différent on va dire c'est viscéral
c'est primaire c'est très amusant vive
le jus d'orange vive le vent